une fin d'après-midi feutrée avait pour
cadre la 10e édition du prix célimène
peintures sculptures photos féminin
était à l'honneur dans le beau jardin de
l'espace raid les
années fêtons le 10e anniversaire du
prêt si vilaine et nous l'avons mis en
place dès que j'ai été élue présidente
pour célébrer bien évidemment cette
journée consacrée aux femmes avec le
volet qui est celui des violences faites
aux femmes mais il me semblait
nécessaire en même temps que nous
laissions les femmes parler d'elle même
et s'exprimer et quel était le meilleur
moyen
que de laisser cette libre expression
que par la libération artistique
encourager l'expression des femmes
artistes amateurs reste l'objectif une
action individuelle pour un apport
collectif on
sait pourquoi ces femmes qui
s'inscrivent et les oeuvres qu'elle
présente à chaque fois on est vraiment
totalement fait agréablement surprises
et on est content d'avoir à la réunion
cette richesse de femmes capables
d'innover à chaque joueur invité
distinguer mesdemoiselles mesdames et
messieurs
applaudissons le premier prix c'est
l'oeuvre femme fatale 2010 hoarau
et ces quelques montées de marches qui
ont conclu en beauté la participation à
ce concours je pense que c'est bien dans
le sens où nos apps on peut feuilleter
un jury et
parce que je rencontre plein de gens qui
font des beaux tableaux et j'ai
l'impression que les tableaux vivent
quand on les regarde il faisait oui
parce que je pensais pas être capable va
de de pouvoir satisfaire le jury quoi
comment les gens voient mon oeuvre
comment comment je serai dans le futur
si je veux faire quelque chose ou non et
et aussi pour mon fils qui est en
métropole en ce moment à et kid qui
m'encouragent beaucoup dans cette voie
pendant tout le mois de mars et artistes
exposeront et depuis dix ans près de
1500 femmes ont eu la chance de faire
passer leur message moi là bas je sais
papa ou maman prisée en fait pour être
tranquille être dans ma bulle donc le
montrer comme ça c'est se montrer un peu
mon univers à moi
qu'en dire aux autres l'audace mais par
passion ce qu'ils aiment faire
s'assumer un peu plus leur à huy non
mais faut y aller faut utiliser ce qu'on
aime et veut justement à la sensualité
j'aimais bien ce côté là en fait montre
un petit bout mais pas tous depuis
l'époque de la muse célimène gaudieux
qui a poussé bien des portes cent
cinquante ans ont passé beaucoup
d'étapes aussi peut pas rester caché
savoir se montrer malgré ce qu'on peut
vivre malgré les difficultés de la vie
il faut savoir les affronter et puis
rester ouverte aux autres estime qu'on
peut avoir de soi en passant par six
états
est ce que c'est si photographie en fait
trop présente pourquoi participer au
concours
pour retrouver mon estime et pour
montrer
chaque femme que non
faut pas qu'elle ait peur de leur estime
d'elle-même